I want to kill you what I do without you
[Music]
so really weird news broke recently and
that is that apparently Jared Leto's
Joker as seen in Suicide Squad is
getting a solo movie this is really
weird for at least three reasons the
first is most people didn't seem to like
Jared Leto's Joker in Suicide Squad the
second is they have not canceled then it
seems to be keep moving along the Joker
origin story that is not part of the DC
EU continuity the one that is supposed
to be directed by todd phillips and
produced by martin scorsese I believe
has joaquin phoenix attached to play the
Joker and then the third thing is always
to bring this character back again a
solo movie really it's good okay so
let's back up I do understand at least
one part of what might be driving the
mentality to think that this is a good
idea and that is that if they're going
to continue to use Jared Leto as the
Joker in there I guess now main
continuity because they're doing out of
continuity stuff now but if they are
gonna continue to use him he needs a
proper highlight basically they need to
rehabilitate him and because if they do
it properly then then what will happen
is the fact that he didn't work in
Suicide Squad will be chalked up to the
way the character was used as opposed to
the character inherently which is part
of why I've always been hesitant to keep
a whole lot of hate onto Jared Leto's
Joker because it doesn't work but the
thing is structurally the character
doesn't work in the film regardless of
who was playing him or how because he's
completely superfluous to anything going
on and yet he's shoehorned in there
anyways
so just on the basic fundamental
storytelling level the character doesn't
work before you even get into
characterization and how he was played
like I I've always been I I don't like
what I see of the Joker and Suicide
Squad but I've always been hesitant to
be overly judgy about it because I feel
like if there was something there it was
completely kneecapped by the way in
which he is oddly placed into this movie
so if they do a something they've chosen
to do a solo movie but if they do
something to highlight this version of
the Joker and basically redeem him as a
character in the eyes of the public then
it can just be written off as one more
thing wrong with Suicide Squad as
opposed to a problem with this character
I am still a little bit surprised that
they're doing it and I have to wonder if
part of the reason that they're doing it
because they're right now there does not
appear to be a writer or director
attached to this but Jared Leto himself
is going to executive producers so I do
have to wonder if it was basically his
condition hey you want me to keep
playing this part then you need you need
to give me something where I know you're
not gonna cut all the work I do and
leave it in the cutting room floor and
it's a waste of my time and that might
have led to why this is being done as a
solo film as opposed to anything else
now again I kind of look at Suicide
Squad and go well if he is making a
demand like that and again that
speculation in my part but if he is
given what I saw he that doesn't feel
worth the ball like because that doesn't
strike me as the way to resuscitate the
Joker if you're gonna resuscitate the
Joker you just need him to be the
villain in a Batman movie I mean
seriously look the Joker is an awesome
character like inherently but he's at
his best when contrasted with Batman in
a vacuum it's not that he's
uninteresting but he's harder to make
work because a huge part of his dynamic
is that
contrast the character that he is the
opposite of you take that out and you're
just with him on his own you lose a
really core element to what works about
him as a character and suddenly his
being all wacky on unhinge doesn't have
something grounded that it's facing off
against it frankly it's more likely to
great that way and that's not me saying
it's impossible to do a joke or solo
movie but that that strikes me as
something if that you should do after
you are certain that you have a version
of the Joker that people really like and
right now frankly frankly DC does not
have that and they seem to know they
don't have that as evidenced by the fact
that they're still going forward with
the but the todd phillips joaquin
phoenix thing so the fact that we are
not only about to have two jokers but
have two solo joker like and that's
another thing that's just gonna be
confusing because if you had just had
the Joker as the villain in a Batman
movie then you could have gone oh okay
well the Jared Leto Joker is the Joker
in this you know mankind no he's the one
who's showing up in in these other
people's movies the one that was on his
own the guy in the solo movies he's
something else but now they're both can
I'm solo movies which just makes it all
the more confusing how the more why are
you doing that
like the whole thing we're doing a solo
Joker movie that was outside the
continuity already kind of made people
going away what and now you're gonna do
another one with a version of the
character that like I said most people
don't seem to like that much even the
people I know who are okay with it turn
that enthusiastic about it so it just is
really bizarre and like I said the only
thing that I can think of is that
they're so desperate to hold on to him I
don't know why you would be but that
they're so desperate to hold on to him
that they're willing to throw him this
bone of a solo movie to keep him on
board but like I understand giving
Harley Quinn or her own spin-off I'm not
entirely sure it's a good idea it could
still work but like I understand why you
do that because most people coming out
of that movie she was one of the few
things people seem to like I did the
Joker not really and
it's just such an odd it just it
contributes to the image that is going
on with Warner Brothers handling DC
properties right now which is that
they're just throwing everything at the
wall to see what sticks they've got so
many things working right now and the
only thing they seem to have backed away
from is the idea of seriously
interconnected films they seem to have
backed off from that which is a good
thing I think for the record at least at
this point in time but aside from that
there they seem to just be throwing
absolutely everything at the wall and I
don't there's there can't possibly be a
plan or at least I don't see how there
could be a plan that allows for it
incorporates all the things that are
currently being worked on it these these
pieces don't fit together this is not a
coherent building of anything I'm not
just saying that because they can't
possibly all be in the same continuity I
don't care if they're in the same
continuity not anymore I saw what
happened when DC tried to really build
stuff around the continuity but like
they they still it needs to not just
appear like they're just throwing
everything out you don't need to have it
be a continuous continuity but you need
to not have it be confusing and to solo
Joker movies with two different Jokers
one of which is in the continuity one of
which isn't is confusing like what why
why would you're doing that it's just
really really weird and I've got no
other words for it at this point I can't
even like get mad about it cuz I'm just
I'm just bemused and befuddled
and I want to come up with another B
words because I want to be alliterative
but I can't oh man yeah so jared leto
getting his own joker movie what are
your thoughts about that whatever they
car if you could make sense of this
please drop something down the comments
let's talk about it there's all the
stuff to do like subscribe follow me on
Twitter podcast patreon etc
etc etc links for all that stuff and
more is down in the description so until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]